talking about kissing boot too your
ex-boyfriend who stars in the movie with
you they asked him about kissing booth
too
he goes hey man i haven't even watched
a kissing booth too now listen there's
this mentality where you're cool in
hollywood
if you say i haven't even seen the movie
and you called him out on it i thought
what was the word you use
i said which actually i'm happy that
we're talking about this um i said
uh jacob watched it he's capping which
capping
means lying um i heard the term
capping on like tick tock and twitter
and instagram and it was and through
friends and i was like oh i guess this
is like the new thing
yeah um apparently it's
it's not um it's it's something that i
should not have used as a white person
and i like i took it down because i was
like oh okay
two accounts on twitter called me out
for it that's why i deleted it not and
people would thought it was because i
you know was like oh no i shouldn't have
said that about him like you know so i
deleted it because of
that and because of the insensitivity
but not because of
i didn't know and i and i'm you know i'm
definitely a person who wants to better
myself every day and so i was like you
know i'm not gonna
sit here and use a term that is not for
me to use and just keep it out there so
i deleted it but i mean yeah so
uh but the tweet was a was was a jovial
it was a jovial thing it wasn't to be
mean it really wasn't i was just like
you know i know i know the kissing booth
fans
they are always so curious about that
tension
of sorts and so i was like i'm just
gonna
i know they'll appreciate this and
that's who it was for was for the fans
to just be like oh my god and they were
you know so you didn't hear from him
when you said that because i mean okay
maybe he did tell the truth maybe he
didn't see it but i i
i did get his permission to tweet it so
that was
so that was fine but um well that's cool
that shows a good sense of humor on his
part